>> WONDERFUL PEOPLE.
HAPPY MONDAY, EVERYONE.
I AM BACK FROM A LONG VACATION.
YOU CAN'T EVEN SEE THE STITCHES.
BUT I LOOKED PRETTY GREAT.
THIS IS HOW I LOOKED BEFORE I
LEFT.
THE DOCTORS REALLY PERFORMED
MIRACLES VERY I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK ALL THE GUEST HOST WHO DI
A GREAT JOB WHILE I WAS GONE.
>> DO NOT ADJUST YOUR TELEVISIO
SCREEN, GREG DID NOT GET MORE
RIDICULOUSLY GOOD-LOOKING.
WE HAVE THIS STAGE CREW REMOVE
THE SIPPY CUP BECAUSE I DON'T
SPILL OR BE LIKE PRESIDENT BIDE
WITHOUT.
>> IT'S A BOOK THAT NO ONE IS
BUYING, CLICK THE PLUS PARETSKY
IT'S THE.
>> THEIR BILL WAS SET AT $0
WHICH IS THE SAME VALUE AS
GREG'S AUTOGRAPH.
NICE PENMANSHIP.
>> SURE, THE READINGS PLUNGED,
IT WAS AN EMBARRASSING DISASTER
AND WE ENDED UP HAVING TO LET G
ALL OF THEM.
AT LEAST THEY THOUGHT OF DOING
THE WHOLE SURE SHIRTLESS.
BOY DID I MISS YOU GUYS.
WHAT I DIDN'T MISS WAS THE NEWS.
NOTHING CALMS YOUR SENSES LIKE
TOTAL NEWS BLACKOUT RATE IT
BEATS AN ALCOHOLIC BLACKOUT,
RIGHT, JB?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
IN FACT, I REALIZED WHEN YOU
DON'T LOOK AT THE NEWS IT'S LIK
ONE OF THOSE I EXAM IT ONLY
MATTERS IF YOU'RE TOLD TO LOOK
AT IT.
WHEN THERE IS NO NEWS, YOU FIND
THE BEST REPLACEMENT IS HYSTERI
FROM THOSE MISERABLE WRETCHES.
SECRETARY OF STATE HE TOLD THE
GUARDIAN THAT IF REPUBLICANS WIN
, THE COUNTRY COULD LOSE THE
RIGHT TO VOTE IN LESS THAN THRE
MONTHS.
THAT'S NOT INSANE.
SO DID SHE TELL THE GUARDIAN,
THE NEWSPAPER, OR HER OWN
PERSONAL LEGAL GUARDIAN WHO KEP
HER FROM HER OWN HAIR.
THAT IS THE NEWS, WHEN THERE
ISN'T ANY YOU READ FOR THE
UNHINGED STAR SPIRIT.
>> ART OUR DEMOCRACY HAS BEEN
PUT IN PERIL.
THERE ARE SEVERAL CRIMES HERE
THAT COULD HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
INCLUDING OBSTRUCTION.
>> IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY HAD TAKEN
THESE DOCUMENTS OUT, THEY WOULD
BE IN JAIL.
>> ED TEXT LEVEL LEGAL EXPERT
ANALYSIS OF THE AFFIDAVIT IS WH
ISN'T HE IN JAIL?
PRESIDENT STICKY FINGERS ALREAD
STOLE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
TOP-SECRET DOCUMENTS.
>> I LOVE HIM.
MAINLY BECAUSE HE LOOKS LIKE MY
DAD'S SHAVING BRUSH.
THAT'S A COMPLIMENT.
ON CRAZY CABLE, TO MAINTAIN
EYEBALLS, EVE GOT TO GET EVEN
CRAZIER.
ELAINE SEEN THERE IMPERSONATING
A DANDELION.
HE HAS CRACKED THE CODE OF CABL
TELEVISION, SAY THE MOST ABSURD
THING AND IT NEVER HAS TO COME
TRUE BECAUSE NO ONE IS KEEPING
SCORE.
IT'S NOT NEWS IT SIMPLY STUFFIN
COINS INTO THE TWITTER SLOT
MACHINE.
EXCEPT THE MATTER HOW DUMB YOUR
IDEAS ARE COMING YOU NEVER HAVE
TO PAY FOR IT BECAUSE IT'S LIKE
TAKING OUT A STUDENT LOAN.
JUST LIKE THE FAMILY PHOTOS ON
MY DESK, IT'S NOT REAL.
AND YOU NOTICE THAT WHEN
SOMETHING REAL COMES ALONG LIKE
THIS, THE WIDELY RESPECTED
STATISTICIAN CLAIMS LIBERAL
PUBLIC HEALTH APPROVAL OF ITS
COVID 19 VACCINE UNTIL AFTER TH
2020 ELECTION THUS DENYING TRUM
A WIN BEFORE VOTERS HEADED TO
THE POOL.
CALLING THEM PUBLIC HEALTH ELIT
IS LIKE CALLING A TAPEWORM OUT
WEIGHT LOSS CONSULTANT.
WHATEVER YOU THINK ABOUT THE
VACCINES, HE HAS PEOPLE THAT WH
IS WORSE THAN HITLER?
WHEN WERE SET READY TO SACRIFIC
LIVES TO KEEP TRUMP FROM LOOKIN
GOOD.
THEY WANTED TO CALL HIM A KILLER
, IF THAT'S NOT THE POT
CALLING THE KETTLE JUSTIN
TRUDEAU.
LOOK, SILVER IS NO TEMP TRUMP
FAN, BUT HE POINTS OUT THAT HIS
ACTIONS LIKELY SAVED HUNDREDS O
THOUSANDS OF LIVES FOR IT IF
THOSE PEOPLE'S NAMES WOULD STIL
HAVE PROBABLY ENDED UP ON THE
DEMS VOTING RULES.
BUT AGAIN, IF YOU BELIEVE TRUMP
IS HITLER, WHAT IS A FEW
THOUSAND DEATHS TO KEEP THEM
FROM KILLING MILLIONS EVEN
THOUGH TRUMP KEPT US AWAY FROM
WHERE IS THE WAY JOE KEEPS US
AWAY FROM COMPLETE SENTENCES.
MAY BE IT'S UNPROVEN, BUT YOU'R
TALKING ABOUT THE SAME PEOPLE
WHO SUPPRESS THE LAPTOP STORY T
WIN AN ELECTION, SO WHY WOULDN'
THEY DO THAT HERE.
MEANWHILE THEY SQUEEZE THE
REMAINING DROPS OF JUICE FROM
THE MAR-A-LAGO RAID.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THOSE NUCLEAR
CODES ANYWAY?
MAYBE THEY ARE UNDER THE BED
WITH A CUP FILMED.
THAT'S MOST ACTION JIMMY FALLON
SAW IN YEARS.
THAT WAS A NEEDLESS CRACK GREAT
VIDEOS OF A CRACKED OUT HUNTER
AND HIS PLAYING HIDE THE HARD
DRIVE, NO STORY THERE UNTIL
MONTHS OR YEARS AFTER THE
ELECTION.
THEN YOU GET THE CONFESSION FRO
A BATTERY-POWERED OBSTACLE ABOU
SOMETHING WE KNEW ALL ALONG
GREAT THEY SEE MY POINT, AMPLIF
THE STORIES LIKE THEIR FORMER
CLINTON ASSOCIATES.
OR RATHER, AMPLIFY STORIES THAT
ARE EASY TO SPECULATE ON LIKE
DOCUMENTS OR RUSSIAN
DISINFORMATION OR KAT'S MARRIAGE
.
I KNOW WHEN I'M ON VACATION WHA
PASSES FOR NEWS HAS NO EFFECT O
ME UNLESS I'M IN MEXICO AND THE
NEWS IS ABOUT A CARTEL MEMBER
LEAVING A HUMAN HEAD AT THE
CONTINENTAL BREAKFAST, I DON'T
CARE.
I ALSO KNOW WHEN JOURNALIST GO
ON VACATION, SO DOES THE
NEWSBREAK IT'S LIKE THEY BOTH
OWN A TIMESHARE TOGETHER AT BOCA
.
SO IN THE ABSENCE OF FACTS, WE
GO FROM NUCLEAR CODES TO
DOCUMENT TO INDICTMENTS.
INDICTMENTS, THE MEDIA LOVES
THIS WORD ASSUMING YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT IT MEANS.
YOU GUYS WATCHING ME RIGHT NOW
DO AND THAT'S WHY THE MEDIA
HATES YOU SOMETIMES.
SOMEONE ONCE SAID YOU COULD
INDICT A HAM SANDWICH, AND I BE
IT WASN'T VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HE WOULD KEEP ON TAMPERING WITH
THE DEFENDER.
SO FAKE NEWS RULES IN REAL NEWS
IS REDEFINED AS HATEFUL SPEECH.
IS THE REQUIRED WAY OF?
YES, BUT DON'T TALK ABOUT IT.
BRING UP THEY ARE ANTI-SEMITIC.
YOU POINT OUT THAT IT'S YOUNG
BLACK KIDS THAT IS RACIST TO.
HIS CITIZENS ON TWITTER CALLS A
AND ADMITTING WING WRONGDOING
AGAINST YOUNG PATIENTS, IT IS
THE CITIZEN WHO IS GUILTY.
A PERSON GETS BANNED FROM
TWITTER FOR DOING WHAT PEOPLE
USED TO CALL JOURNALISM, SO
WHAT'S LEFT IS AN ARRAY OF
BOTTOMLESS WHAT-IFS THAT ARE
PERFECT FOR HAPPY DRAMA QUEENS
ON CABLE, THIS DEATH THAT IS
IGNORED AND PROBABLY REAL THAT
COULD AFFECT YOU, HOLD YOUR
APPLAUSE, HOLD YOUR APPLAUSE.
THAT WAS GRATUITOUS.
I NEED A SHOWER AFTER THAT.
I ACTUALLY DO.
I STINK.
BUT REAL STUFF IN LIFE,
JOURNALIST DON'T HAVE TIME FOR
THAT EIGHT USED TO BE THE DOG
DAYS OF AUGUST WHEN PRODUCERS
WOULD DO ANYTHING TO PLUG A
WHOLE, EVEN ASKING AMATEURS TO
HOST FOR ME.
TUNE INTO ONE NATION AT 7:00
O'CLOCK AND 8:00 O'CLOCK.
IN MY NOT ENOUGH?
>> APPARENTLY NOT.
I AM SO TIRED OF HAVING TO DO
CHARITY FOR THIS GUY.
IT'S LIKE SPONSORING A CHILD
FROM OVERSEAS BUT THIS ONE
COMMUTES FROM LONG ISLAND.
FAKE NEWS IS YEAR-ROUND, IT'S
THE PROFIT MODEL, SO WHAT TO DO
WITH THE MEDIA HACKS, I SAY TUR
THEM ON AND A ONE-WAY TRIP TO
SOMEWHERE THEY CAN'T EVEN TWEET
FROM BARRY TELL THE LADIES OF
THE VIEW TO PACK EXTRA MUUMUUS
BECAUSE THEY WANT BECOMING BACK
SOON.
MAYBE WHEN THEY'RE ON PERMANENT
VACATION THE REST OF US CAN
FINALLY GET SOME PEACE.
WELCOME, TONIGHT'S GUESTS, SHE
KEEPS HER WINE WHERE SHE KEEPS
HER CHILDREN, INSIDE A CARDBOAR
BOX.
FOX NEWS ANCHOR AND THERE IS.
HE IS OUR FAVORITE BREWER, THIS
SIDE OF ANHEUSER-BUSCH, THE
COMEDIAN THE NEW YOUTUBE SPECIAL
, SOMEBODY HAD TO SAY IT
JIM BREWER.
SHE IS ONE HEMINGWAY YOU WILL
NEVER FIND IN CUBA, MOLLY
HEMINGWAY.
AND HIS NAME IS AN UNDERCOVER
STRIPPER AND HIS BUCK SEXTON.
WHAT I ALWAYS LIKE ABOUT YOU IS
A NEWS ANCHOR, YOU NEVER TRIED
TO GET PEOPLE TO TRUST YOU.
NO.
NO, FIRST OF ALL, YOU ALWAYS
WANT TO UNDERSELL AND THAT IS M
MOTTO IN LIFE VERY JUST SET THE
EXPECTATIONS LOW.
IN THAT WAY IF YOU ACTUALLY GET
SOMETHING RIGHT PEOPLE ARE LIKE
THAT'S INCREDIBLE.
>> IT IS FUNNY HOW THEY USE THE
SAME PHRASES, THE USE THE SAME
FOCAL AND THEY HAVE NO MEMORY O
EVERYTHING THEY SAID BEFORE
WHICH IS LIKE IF TRUE OR SHE'S
GOING TO JAIL, WHAT IS IT, ARE
YOU OBLIGATED TO HAVE AMNESIA I
ORDER TO DO THE NEWS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
YOU JUST HAVE TO TELL THE NEWS
IS IF YOU ACTUALLY BELIEVE IT
AND MOST OF THE TIME IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE SO YOU'VE JUST GOT
TO FAKE IT.
THAT'S WHERE TRUMP CAME OUT WIT
FAKE NEWS FREIGHT A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE AND THE MEDIA ARE FAKING
IT UNTIL THEY MAKE IT IT, BUT A
LOT OF THEM AREN'T MAKING IT.
>> IF THEY FAKE IT UNTIL THEY
MAKE IT, THEY SHOULD GET FIRED.
I'M SURE HE WOULD LOVE TO COME
ON, YOU'VE BEEN SO KIND TO HIM.
>> I THINK I WOULD FETCHING HIM.
ISN'T THAT REALLY WHAT IT'S ALL
ABOUT?
JIM, WHERE YOU STAND ON THIS?
YOU ARE NOT IN THE NEWS, DO YOU
FEEL LIKE WHENEVER YOU TURN ON
THE NEWS YOU'RE GETTING FED
OVERLOAD?
>> HONESTLY, ANYTHING THEY SAY,
I KNOW IS COMPLETE OPPOSITE.
WHATEVER IS GOING ON, I KNOW
IT'S A FULL-BLOWN NITROGENOUS
WASTE AT THE END OF THE DAY.
I DON'T BUY ANY NEWS WHATSOEVER.
EXCEPT FOR FOX NEWS OF COURSE
BECAUSE WE HERE DELIVER NOTHING
BUT THE TRUTH.
>> OF COURSE.
>> WHILE YOU LIVE IN FLORIDA.
>> I LIVE IN NAPLES, FLORIDA.
HOME OF THE PASTEL COLOR PANTS.
CAN THAT PRESS MEDIA EVER REGAI
TRUST?
>> NO.
>> ZERO.
THEY LIED THROUGH THEIR TEETH.
AND BACK TO, YOU CAN HATE TRUMP
ALL YOU WANT, HE'S THE FIRST
HUMAN BEING THEY CAME OUT FAKE
NEWS FAKE NEWS FAKE NEWS, FAKE
NEWS, AND FOR CENTURIES, FOR
YEARS.
AND IT IS WORLDWIDE.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> IS THAT AUSTRALIAN OR NEW
ZEALAND?
>> IT WAS SOMEWHERE IN BETWEEN.
I LIKED IT ANYWAY.
MOLLY, DO YOU FIND IT WEIRD WHE
YOU GO AWAY ON VACATION YOU COM
BACK, WHENEVER I GO AWAY,
NOTHING BIG HAPPENS SO I FEEL
LIKE IT'S ABOUT MAYBERRY.
>> YOU CAN TAKE TWO DAYS OFF AN
YOU COME BACK AND IT'S LIKE
YOU'RE IN A COMPLETELY DIFFEREN
COUNTRY MAJOR THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED.
I TOOK MY ONE DAY OF VACATION
THE DAY OF THE MAR-A-LAGO RAID.
I CAME BACK AT MIDNIGHT AND I
SAID WHAT HAPPENED HERE?
, I REALLY CHOSEN THE WRONG DAT
TAKEOFF.
BUT THE MEDIA ARE SO BAD AT
THESE THINGS.
PARTICULAR WITH THAT STORY I'VE
BEEN FINDING IT FUNNY HOW PEOPL
ACT LIKE WE DIDN'T JUST GO
THROUGH THE FBI FAKING EVIDENCE
TO GO AFTER THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
AND DOING ALL SORTS OF
DEPLORABLE THINGS AND NOW THERE
ACTING LIKE THIS IS JUST A
BRAND-NEW DAY, THAT NEVER HAPPEN
, THEY NEVER RAN THE
RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX.
YOU HEAR PEOPLE SAY YOU JUST
DON'T KNOW WHAT WE DON'T KNOW.
I HEARD THAT FOR YEARS DURING
THE RUSSIAN COLLUSION HOAX I
DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT ANYMORE.
>> IT'S PRETTY FUNNY BECAUSE
THIS FACT DEPRESSION STORY, IF
TRUE, IT WOULD BE HUGE.
BUT WHY DIDN'T IT GO ANYWHERE?
I WAS AWAY, I THOUGHT THIS IS
GOING TO EXPLODE, I WISH I WAS
AT WORK, BUT THEN IT JUST KINDA
PETERED AWAY AND THEN THEY
STARTED DOING MORE STUFF ABOUT
THE RATE INSTEAD.
WHEN SOMETHING IS HAPPENING THE
GO BIG ON THE OTHER SIDE.
>> I WROTE BOOK CALLED GREG
ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION I TOLD
THE STORY IN THE BOOK PFIZER
CAME OUT AFTER THE ELECTION AND
ANNOUNCED THEY HAD IN OCTOBER
GOTTEN EVERYTHING THEY NEEDED T
DO IN ORDER TO GET THE VACCINE
APPROVED AND IT WAS CLEAR PEOPL
WERE OPENLY SAYING THAT THEY HA
TO DELAY THIS ANNOUNCEMENT UNTI
AFTER THE ELECTION AND YES, I
MEAN THERE WERE SO MANY THINGS
THAT WERE DONE THAT WE'RE
IMPROPER TO AFFECT THAT ELECTIO
AND COULD GET REMEMBER READING
THAT IN YOUR BOOK.
FANTASTIC BOOK.
YOU CAN STILL GET IT.
ITS IT'S AVAILABLE?
>> IT IS.
WHAT PROFESSOR DID YOU ROLL?
>> IN SHOWED THEM A QR COLD OF
WHERE THEY THAT.
DID YOU GET MARRIED OR SOMETHING
?
>> ENGAGED.
>> TO FOX NEWS EMPLOYEE.
>> OH REALLY, FOX NEWS.
YOU KNOW, I NEVER THOUGHT YOU
AND JUDGE JEANINE WOULD HIT IT
OFF, BUT IT GAVE GIVE THE JUDGE
IS A LOT OF FUN.
THROUGH STORY.
>> WE WOULD HAVE A HELLUVA TIME.
>> YOU'RE KIDDING ME.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE ZUCKERBERG
STUCK?
HE GOES TO ROGAN AND SAYS THIS
INCREDIBLE THING IN THEN BUSY
TRYING TO PUT UP THE FBI
RESPONSE FOR IT.
>> LYING IS THE POINT.
THAT EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
UNDERSTAND THIS NOW.
THIS ISN'T A SURPRISE OR HOW
COULD THEY HAVE GOT THIS ALL
WRONG WHEN YOU HAVE HELMETS
WITHIN THE FBI LET IT COME
FORWARD AND TALK ABOUT ELECTION
DISINFORMATION.
THERE WAS NOT A SINGLE
MISINFORMATION TIDBIT IT IS
ALWAYS REPUBLICAN DISINFORMATION
.
WHEN FAUCI, I THINK PEOPLE HAD
TO GET IT TO THEIR HEAD THAT HE
WAS JUST THE HEALTH DEEP STATE.
HE WAS THE BUREAUCRAT OF MANY
DECADES.
IT WAS A MISTAKE FOR TRUMP TO
KEEP THEM ON.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
TRUMP HAS BEEN HONEST ABOUT HIS
PERSONAL DECISION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALL THESE OTHER
INSTITUTIONS IS TO BE BATTLING
PROPAGANDA MACHINES FOR THE LEFT
.
I WORKED FOR SOME OF THEM BY TH
WAY, 51 OR WHATEVER IT WAS FROM
A THIRD NOT SO STUPID THAT THEY
THOUGHT THE LAPTOP WAS
MISINFORMATION, THEY WENT THEIR
CREDIBILITY ON FIRE PURPOSELY T
GIVE FIRE TO THE SHUTDOWN OF TH
STORY SO THAT RELATIVELY LOW
INFORMATION FOES CAN SAY WELL,
GUESS THERE'S MORE CIA PEOPLE
GOT THAT.
>> WE HAVE TO DO A HEARING 50 T
DAYS OF HEARINGS TO INTERVIEW
EACH PERSON THAT SIGNED THAT
LETTER.
I WANT TO APOLOGIZE FOR HURTING
YOU WITH THE LADIES BY SAYING
YOU ARE ENGAGED BECAUSE IT
PROBABLY NOT GOING TO BE DATING
AS MUCH.
I MEAN YOUR NAME IS BUCK SEXTON.
WHOSE MONOGAMOUS WITH THAT NAME.
WHAT'S BAD IS YOUR FORENAME IS
PROBABLY LIKE JERRY SLAVIN SPIEL
.
OR IS THAT THE OPPOSITE?
I AM IN IDIOT.
WE NEED MORE BLUE-COLLAR
JOURNALISTS, PEOPLE THAT DIDN'T
GO TO COLLEGE, THAT'S WHAT WE
NEED T